a model hospital with a climate
conscious design and built with bare
minimum of resources now named best new
building in the world
so when we started the design the first
thing we realized was the budget or the
fund were going to be the greatest
concern and that's why we have employed
all local materials local craftsmen
but at the same time we realized that
the people of us in the surrounding
areas were villages and so we had to be
sure that they would accept this as a
place that they can come for care
the international riba award has been
well received by those who live and work
in the area
no we have not seen any hospital like
these before it blends in very well with
nature nothing artificially is used even
the bricks are natural it's clean neat
and beautiful both inside and outside
compared to other buildings in the area
as locals we feel proud
the impact of climate change and nature
was a major consideration for the
architects
we realized that the landscape was
changing the agricultural landscape was
changing from agriculture people were
moving into shrimp farming because of
the rising sea levels and the sea water
that has come in
and even underground
so
we had to sort of look into those issues
in detail study and research why this
was happening and what were the villages
doing to sort of combat that and we sort
of took their wisdom and brought it into
the design of this hospital
the canal inside the building plays a
crucial role the canal also helps at a
different level it helps with
microclimatic cooling
so it helps to
avoid any form of air conditioning and
power consumption in the entirety of the
campus
the other aspect of
this canal is it is a divider so we were
able in terms of the zoning of the
hospital we were able to separate very
clearly the outdoor departments and the
indoor departments in patient
departments
space was designed not just for hospital
wards treatment rooms and operating
theaters but for general healing and
wellness too
when you walk into this building it
doesn't appear like a hospital it blends
in so well with the local landscape and
topography there's a sense of belonging
to the nature
if we don't take care of our nature of
our environment in all aspects and in
every corner of our planet
we will not be able to save our home
which is this beautiful beautiful place
that we have
the judges praised the architects for
putting care and humanity at the heart
of the design chandra
al jazeera shotkara bangladesh